بعد اعدامها مجيد رضا رحمه ورد ايران
تهاجم منزل اسرته وتهدد افراد عائلته
ابو عجيله يمثل لفتره وجيزه امام القضاء
الامريكي والاعلامي ينشر اول صوره له منذر
اعتقاله
اداره
امريكيه افريقيه باعلان المساعدات ب 55
مليار دولار للقارات السمراء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره اهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر
البدايه من ايران حيث اظهرت قناه اوت تودي
على تطبيق التلجرام ان القوات الايرانيه
هاجمت منزله عائله مجيد رضا
رهواند او رهن ورد الذي كانت اعدمته في
وقت سابق وحددت عائلته ووضعت كتلا
الاسمنتيه امام المنزل قبل ان تقطع المياه
والكهرباء والغاز والهاتف عن العائله
الاهلي
[موسيقى]
ثاني
السجن
[موسيقى]
منا جهاتها حطت منظمه العفو الدوليه
المجتمع الدوليه على اتخذ كافه الاجراءات
اللازمه للضغط على السلطات الايرانيه لوقف
عمليه الاذان
العالمي للشاب في ايران يفضح نظامها
القضائي الذي يستخدمه نظام كاداه للقمع
والانتقام من المتظاهرين الذين شاركوا في
الاحتياجات الاخيره في البلاد
ماما
مجلس حقوق الانسان التابع للامم المتحده
عندهشته وشعوره بالفزع بعد اعدام ثاني
المحتاجين في ايران مجيد رضا رحمه ورد في
اقل من ثلاثه اسابيع من اعتقاله وقال
المجلس في بيان ان اعدام مجيد رضا ينظر
بالخطر على بقيه المحتجين المحكومين
بالاعدام واضاف المجلس بان استخدامه عقوبه
الاعدام ضد المحتاجين لا يتوافقوا مع الحق
في الحياه
ردا على سؤال لمراسله العربيه حول مصير
الرهائن الامريكيين المحتجزين في ايران
اكد مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيكس17
انه ملتزم بمواصله العمل لاطلاق السراحي
جميع السجناء مشيرا في الوقت ذاته الى ان
واشنطن ستستمر في دعم المحتجين الايرانيين
في معركه الكرامه والحقوق
لقد اتيحت لي الفرصه لقاء عائله
مراد في الايام القليله الماضيه كما ساحضر
بفرصه مقابله عائله عماد شكري لذا فقط
مع العديد من الاشخاص الذين تاثروا شخصيا
باعتقال افراد عائلاتهم المحتجزين ظلما
بشكل غير قانوني في ايران وانا ملتزم
شخصيا بهذا الامر
للامن القومي اقضي عشرات ان لم يكن مئات
ساعات في العمل على هذه الحالات للا معي
مع هذه العائلات وساستمر في ذلك بينما
نمضي قدما احيانا كانت هناك مشكلات تتعلق
بالجدول الزمني لكن على مدار العام الماضي
فتحت لي الفرصه للقاء العديد من العائلات
من الرهائن والمحتجازين في روسيا
وافغانستان وفنزويلا وايران والصين واماكن
اخرى ايضا وساواصل القيامه بذلك وفيما
يتعلق بالسؤال عن ما نفعله فيما يتعلق
بدعم المحتجين في ايران لقد راينا جمله من
الاعلانات المتعلقه بالعقبات على اولئك
الذين يرتكبون هذه الانتهاكات الجسيمه
الحقوقيه وهذا القمع لم نقوم بذلك بانفسنا
بالتنسيق اخرى في جميع انحاء العالم من
اجل اداره دوليه لما يحدث بالاضافه الى
ذلك اتخذنا خطوات لمحاوله تسهيل قدره
الايرانيين على التواصل فيما بينهم ومن ثم
التواصل مع العالم الخارجي حول ما يحدث في
بلادهم حتى تمكن من تسليط الضوء الكافي
على المسؤولين عن ذلك ومحاسبتهم سنستمر في
القيام بهذه الاشياء او بتوجيه من الرئيس
الذي تحدث بشكل مباشر للغايه وواضح وعاطفي
حول هذا الموضوع مؤكدا ان هذه الحكومه تقف
الى جانب حقوق المتظاهرين السلميين وحقوق
المراه وتسعى للدفاع عن كرهته بالانسانيه
وحقوق الناس في كل مكان وتتحدث علنا من
اجل حياه افضل استاذ واصل يوم القيامه
بذلك
اعلن الاتحاد الاوروبي عن حزمتين من
العقوبات ضد السلطات الايرانيه تتصل
الحزمه الاولى بحمله قمع المتظاهرين حيث
تضم 20 مسؤولا وكيانا بالاضافه الى مؤسسه
الاذاعه والتلفزيون الايراني اه فيما يتصل
بالحزمه الثانيه هو تزويد ايران لروسيا
بمسيرات تستخدمها في حرب اوكرانيا وتضم
الحزمه الثانيه ايضا اربعه مسؤولين من
بينهم ثلاثه جنرالات في الحرس الثوري
واربعه كيانات متخصصه في صناعه المسيرات
بعدين قاسيه المعلقه المشامله للعلاقات
المتساعده التعقيد مع ايران اكد وزراء
خارجيه دول الاتحاد دعمهم للتطلعات الشعب
الايراني المشروعه نحو الحريه
بشان تزوي طيران روسيا بالمسيرات وحمله
المسجد ضد المتظاهرين
حول حمله القمع المنهج ضد المتظاهرين
وتشمل القائمه الاضافيه واحده وعشرين
اثنان وذلك في نطاقه دعم الاتحاد للشعب
الايراني الوزراء الاوروبيون يحذرون ايران
بشده من عواق باي دعم عسكريا اضافيا تقدمه
الى روسيا خاصه الصواريخ البالستيه قصيره
الامل
نتخذ عقوبات اضافيه ضد الذين يزودون روسيا
بمسيرات تستخدمها في قصف اوكرانيا وارتكاب
جرائم الحرب هذه
المباحثات الاوروبيه
حيث ابتعدت ايران عن مقتضيات البرنامج
النووي ولم تتخذ القرارات المناسبه للتوسل
الى احياء الدفاع
والعقوبات التي تصدر اليوم
لان احياء الاتفاق النووي مفيد بالنسبه
للجانب الايراني
لا تزعل الحصول على تزود النوويه
الاتحاد الاوروبي عازم على ان لا تتزوج
ايران ابدا بالسلاح النووي ويدعو الدوله
كافه الى تنفيذ القرار الدولي
2231 لعام 2015 وفي ذلك رساله مباشره الى
طهران البيان الاوروبي ورد في ست صفحات
ونصف الصفحات من الرسائل التي تضمنها دعوه
الاتحاد الاوروبي ايران الى التعاوني مع
لجنه تقصي الحقائق الدوليه في العنف
المتواصلي في الداخل الايراني
وتحذير الاتحاد الاوروبي ايران من عواقب
التزويدها روسيا بالصواريخ البالسيه ان هي
فعلت او ستفعل
ويفهموا من سياق البيان الاوروبي ككل نضج
الموقف هنا
واحتمال توجهه الى مجلس الامن اذا استحال
التفاهم مع ايران
ردينا الفريق العربيه
افاده مراسل العربيه بمثله مسعود ابو
عجيله المتهم بصنع قنبله هجوم الوكربي
امام المحكمه في العاصمه واشنطن لفتره
وجيزه وابلغ بوجيلا او ابلغ ابو جهله قاضي
التحقيق الامريكي روبن ماري وذر خلال جلسه
الاستماع الاولى عبر مترجم بانه لن يتحدث
الا بعد ان يجتمع مع محاميه وذلك بعد
توجيه المحكمه ثلاثتهم له تتعلق بتفجير
الطائره وقتل امريكيين كما سئل ابو جويلا
عن وضعه الصحي واجاب بانه يعاني من امراض
ويتناول ادويه
[موسيقى]
ملاحظه اكثر من ثلاثه عقود انتهت بوقوع
المتهم بصناعه قنبله تفجير الاقربين مسعود
المغربي
[موسيقى]
قضيه بعجيله بدات ملابساتها عام 2018
بعد اعوام قليله اعاده الولايات المتحده
لفتح ملف اللقبي عبر توجيه التهامات رسميه
لبعجيله تتعلق بالارهاب الى انه ظل موجود
في الاراضي الليبيه مع تعاهد المسؤولين
الامريكيين والاسكتلنديين بالعمل على
تسريبه حتى يمكن محاكمته فعليه
[موسيقى]
في نوفمبر الماضي
بطل عقل المصدي عليكم
لكنها لم تعلن حتى الان كيف وصل القبضتها
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعد الفاصل
قتلى وجرحى في انفجار سهل في فندق في
افغانستان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اكد مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي في البيت الابيض جيكسلفين ان
الولايات المتحده تستعد لاستضافه القمه
الامريكيه الافريقيه اليوم واوضح سلفا ان
الولايات المتحده ستلتزم بتقديم 55 مليار
دولار لافريقيا على مدى سنوات الثلاث
المقبله كما قال السلزم بان من بين اعمال
القمه مناقشه انتخابات عام 2023
والديمقراطيه في القاره مع مجموعه صغيره
من الزعماء واضح مستشار الامن القومي انا
بعدين سيقيموا مادبه عشاء لنحو 50 من
الزعماء الافارقه ويعلن دعم الولايات
المتحده للانضمام الاتحاد الافريقي الى
مجموعه العشرين مشيرا الى ان الولايات
المتحده لن تفرض شروطا خلال القمه
الافريقيه لدعم حرب اوكرانيا
اهلا يا تنظيم وداعش مسؤوليته عن هجوم
المستهدفه فندق في كابول وكانت حكومه
الطالبان اعلنت مقتل ثلاثه مسلحين اطلقوا
النار في فندق بالعاصمه الافغانيه مضيفه
في بيان بانه لا يوجد قتلى في صفوف
الاجانب المقيمين في الفندق الذي يرتاده
عاده رجال اعمال صينيون واوضح مراسل
العربيه ان الفندق الذي شهد الهجوم يقع
قرب القصر الرئاسي ومقرات البعثات
الدبلوماسيه
[موسيقى]
اقر الجيش الاساليب مسؤوليه جنوده عن مقتل
الطفله الفلسطينيه جناز كارنا خلال عمليه
اقتحام واشتباكات المسلحه في مدينه جنين
وفي حين عبر الجيش الاسرائيلي عن اسفي
لمقتل الطفله بشكل غير متعمد وفق البان
قالت عائله الطفله انها وافقت على تشريعها
حتى يتسنى لهم ملاحقه اسرائيل قضائيا في
المحاكم الدوليه
وسط التبادل كثيفا لاطلاق النار في جنين
بين قوات اسرائيليه اقتحمت المدينه
لاعتقال مطاردين ومقاتلين فلسطينيين قررت
الطفله جنى وفق روايه اهلها ان تصعد الى
سطح المنزل لانقاذ حياه قطتها فعجلها قناص
اسرائيليون بضع رصاصات لتفارقه هي الحياه
وتنجو القطه جنى
قاعده بالدار يعني طفله طلعت من براءه جنى
طفولتها
كانت موجوده هون على السطح
عائله الطفله والنيابه الفلسطينيه قرارات
توثيق عمليه القتل قانونيا وصل محققونا
فلسطينيون الى المكان وتم اخذ القياسات
ونقلت جثث الطفله لتشريح الطبي لكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي سرعان ما اعترف في بيان رسمي
بمسؤوليته عن قتلها مبديا اسفه وعدم تعمده
استهداف مدني
ووسط حاله من الغضب والمطالبه بالرد شيع
المئات من اهالي مدينه جنين جثمان الطفله
جنى بمشاركه مقاتلين لم يعودوا يابهون على
ما يبدوا بوضع اللثام على وجوههم او
اخفائها هويتهم
يا بلادي العام الحالي في الضفه الغربيه
هو الاكثر دمويه منذ نحو 20 عاما
166 فلسطينيه قتلوا برصاص الجيش
الاسرائيلي منهم صفه 56 طفلا اخرهم الطفله
جنى حيث كان اعتراف الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالمسؤوليه عن قتلها والاعتذار سابقه
نادره في خضم الصراع القائمه عبد الحفيظ
جوعان العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه
في غابات شمال فرنسا اوضاعا ماساويه
بانتظار فرصه الوصول الى بريطانيا الشرطه
تحاول منعهم من خلال مصادره حاجيتهم ومنعم
منظمات من تقديم المساعده لهم
هربا من ازمات وحروب في بلدانهم الاصليه
يتجمع على طرفي سكه القطار المهجوره هذا
الشماليه فرنسا مهاجرون من جنسيات افغانيه
وسودانيه وحتى سوريه املا بتحقيق حلم
العبور من فرنسا الى بريطانيا لكن عبر
قوارب متهالكه في البحر هنا اقام
المهاجرون في غابات مدينه كالي عالم
موازيا ينغلق على نفسه وينقسم الى مجموعات
السوداني مع السوداني والافغاني مع
الافغاني اما لحظه التقاء الجميع فهي فقط
حين تاتي المساعدات وسائل الاعلام غير
المرحب بها هنا لان قنوات فرنسيه دابت على
شيطنت هؤلاء والتحريض عليهم فسرعان
ماتعاله الاصوات معترضه على وجودنا طب طب
كويس
ان الشرطه الفرنسيه مسؤوله عن هذا الوضع
فقبل يوم من وصولنا جرفت مركبات الشرطه
خياما وطعاما واغطيه ثم غادر التريكه مئات
المهاجرين في برد قارس لقتل حلمهم في
العبور الى بريطانيا
التي احضرناها وضعوا حواجز لكي يمنع
المنظمات من المرور وتقديم المساعده
للمهاجرين
لان طلب اللجوءه رفض في فرنسا وبعض اخر
يسعى للمشمل مع عائله له هناك مثل انجو
مهاجر كردي ايراني قابل بالتحدث الينا بعد
رفض عشرات من زملائه فقدنا بعيدا عن
تجمعات المهاجرين والمهربين الذين يندسون
بينهم منتحرين صفه مهاجر حتى لا نثيره
غضبهم
بريطانيا
لهذا السبب الكل يريد الذهاب الى بريطانيا
الوضع هنا سيء جدا الطقس بارد والشرطه
عدوانيه انها تاتي باستمرار لتصادر خيامنا
واكياس النوم نحن لسنا بخير هنا قبل عام
تماما غرق قارب يقول له 27 مهاجرا ابحر من
شواطئ كاليه بعض المهاجرين هنا لم يسمعوا
بالقصه لان فتى هي محطه عبور لا اكثر
تتجدد فيها الوجوه لكن الحلم واحد بالنسبه
للجميع وهو الوصول الى شواطئ بريطانيا
التي يمكن رؤيتها بالعين المجرده فاضده
العربيه كالي
في اخبار المونديال تقام اليوم المباراه
الاولى من الدوري نصف النهائي بين
الارجنتين وكرواتيا بعد مفاجاه الاخيره
باقصاء المنتخب البرازيلي احد المرشحين
للفوز باللقب وفوز الارجنتين على هولندا
ليتقابله في نصف النهائي الاول في البطوله
في ما يلتقي المنتخب المغربي مع نظيره
الفرنسيه غدا في نفس الدور العربيه التقت
في المغرب مجموعه من اصدقاء وجيران النجم
المغربي يوسف النصيري في الحي الذي نشا في
مدينه فاس النصيري لاعب كبير همم مرضي
الوالدين همم الهداف تاريخي الفريق الوطني
همم هداف تاريخي ديال همم جوجكو كاس
العالم 2018
والحمد لله قدر يوصل العالميه
فضل جوده دياله الكبيره بالنسبه ليوسف
الناصري ماشي ماشي صاحبي ولا ولد حومتي بل
هو خايس صغير
للناس معه في المنزل نتاعهم شركت معهم
طعام مع والدين مع مول العزيزه مع بو
ادريس مع اخوته كاملين بالنسبه ليوسف
النصيري هو واحد الفخر مدينه فاس بالنسبه
للمنتخب الوطني
في نهايتنا شهاده تفكيرهم بابرز عناوينها
بعد اعدامها مجيد رضا رحنا ورد ايران
تهاجم منزل اسرته وتهدد افراد عائلته
لا يمثل لفتره وجيزه امام القبائل
الامريكي والاعلامي ينشر اول صوره له منذ
اعتقاله
افريقيه باعلان مساعده ب 55 مليار دولار
للقاره السمراء
نهايه نشره اللقاء
[موسيقى]